kathy wood became a called hero two
years ago for a generation of investors
raised on the mantra that stocks only go
up
an early acolyte of elon musk and tesla
wood steered arkan vests through the
early months of the pandemic with arc
innovation etf gaining 157 percent in
2020 but ark's woe started shortly after
large holdings and stay-at-home stocks
like zoom roku and teledoc health
struggled in 2021 and the arc innovation
etf retreated 23 percent
2022 has been a painful reality check
for woods arc invest and its loyal
disciples
the arc innovation etf crashed 52 this
year and the firm's assets under
management and all of its etfs declined
from a peak of more than 60 billion
dollars in february 2021 to 16 billion
dollars by the end of april 2022
as a result wood has dropped off the
forbes list of america's richest
self-made women this year her estimated
net worth of 140 million dollars is down
from 400 million dollars last year this
falls short of the 215 million dollar
cutoff needed to make the top 100 on the
2022 list
even so she predicted ark would return
40 annually over the next five years as
her losses deepened she doubled down in
april saying ark would rebound and gain
50 percent a year she also said a
six hundred dollar price target for
tesla shares by 2026 implying a near
five trillion dollar valuation
woods investors have not jumped ship
either the ark innovation etf has seen
two billion dollars in inflows this year
although other etfs have had outflows
partially offsetting that amount
morningstar analyst robbie greengold
says a possible source of continued
investment in the fund is a slew of
products that either amplify or sell
short its holdings and risk-taking
investors have kept trying to buy the
dip green gold added quote there's
probably something to be said about
kathy wood's charisma and her continued
presence in publicly available webinars
youtube videos and also in the media she
seems to inspire a lot of confidence in
retail investors
for now wood still has a large enough
war chest to be patient for a turnaround
and her business generates plenty of
revenue charging modest annual fees on
its assets and also partnering with
foreign issuers such as japan's nico
asset management for around 10 billion
dollars in additional assets classified
as non-discretionary
you